PASSENGERS.
RENE MARSH IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: SEVERE TURBULENCE
AND A MID-AIR BRAWL AND A FLIGHT
ATTEND
ATTENDANT SCALDED WITH HOT WATER
AND AN EXIT OPENED.
A FRIGHTEN WEEK PACKED WITH
PASSENGERS.
AN AMERICAN AIRLINES FLIGHT FROM
DALLAS TO SOUTH KOREA HIT SEVERE
TURBULENCE.
14 PEOPLE HURT AND FIVE
HOSPITALIZED.
THIS WOMAN WAS STRUCK IN THE
HEAD WITH A GLASS PLATE AND FOOD
CARTS OVERTURNED.
THE TURBULENCE CAUSED BY A
STRONG WINTER STORM OFF THE
COAST OF JAPAN.
THE PLANE MAKES AN EMERGENCY
LANDING.
EVERYONE IS NOW OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
THE PROBLEM ON THIS THAI AIR
ASIA FLIGHT, A PASSENGER UPSET
ABOUT HER SEATING ASSIGNMENT
TOSSES HOT NOODLES ON A FLIGHT
ATTENDANT, SCALDING HER.
>> AIRLINES WOULD APPRECIATE
EVEN STRICTER LAWS ABOUT THIS.
BUT THEY, THEMSELVES, CAN DO A
LITTLE MORE THAN THEY ARE DOING
AND IT COULD COME DOWN TO JUST
ANNOUNCING IT.
RIGHT AFTER YOU TALK ABOUT NOT
SPOKING IN THE -- SMOKING IN THE
LAVATORY OR YOU FACE A FINE ARKS
ANNOUNCE THERE COULD BE A 25,000
DOLLARS FINE FOR CAUSING A
DISTURBANCE ON A FLIGHT.
>> AND THEN THERE IS THIS UNITED
AIRLINES FLIGHT FROM LONDON TO
NEW YORK.
THE PILOT HAD TO CIRCLE OVER THE
ENGLISH CHANNEL FOR THREE HOURS
DUMPED FUEL BEFORE LANDING
SAFELY.
AND CAUGHT ON CAMERA, TWO WOMEN
IN A MID-AIR SMACKDOWN.
ON BOARD AIR CHINA, THE FIGHT
REPORTEDLY STEMMING FROM A
CRYING BABY.
>> THE GOOD NEWS IS, THESE ARE
STILL THE EXCEPTION NOT THE
RULE.
MOST LIGHTS GO OFF WITH NONE OF
THESE KINDS OF PROBLEMS BUT IT
DOES HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: FROM 2007 TO 2013,
MORE THAN 28,000 CASES OF UNRULY
PASSENGERS RECORDED BY THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, RANGING FROM
VIOLENCE TO NOT FOLLOWING SAFETY
INSTRUCTIONS.
>> YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
PRESUMABLY ARE NICE PEOPLE AT
OTHER